[Musique]
bonjour stéphanie très heureux de vous
retrouver depuis washington
alors stéphanie le suspense reste entier
quelles sont les dernières informations
bonsoir olivier effectivement c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire suspense entier
ont folle je dirais presque l'hystérie
et 6 aux états unis depuis ce matin les
chaînes info passent leur temps devant
ces cartes qui se colore en bleu ou en
rouge c'est en fonction
incertitude effectivement nombreuses
même si on parle davantage donné à jo
maiden alors qu'il est mais restons
évidemment extrêmement prudente en cause
l'inconnu dans plusieurs états clefs
vous savez ces fameux swing states donc
vous parle depuis très longtemps
ces états dans lesquels se joue
véritablement l'élection alors on va
procéder par ordre
ce que l'on sait déjà le candidat
n'aurait à l'heure actuelle 238 voix de
grands électeurs contre 214 pour donald
trump
alors pas de surprise un dans les états
traditionnellement ancrée à droite ou à
gauche chez les démocrates ont
l'emportent sans surprise sur la côte
est ce dans des villes comme new york
sur la côte ouest également en
californie donald trump lui l'emportent
à priori au texas avec ses 38 précieux
grands électeurs dans l'ohio 18 voix de
grands électeurs et surtout dans le plat
très convoité floride 29 grands
électeurs alors désormais tous les
regards sont tournés sur ces six états
clés dont je vous parlais il ya quelques
instants où les jeux ne sont pas encore
faits on attend les dépouillent les
dépouillements
le nevada tout d'abord où abdou bâ
d'hommes sans avoir alors qu il l
avantage le wisconsin avantage également
à joe biden le michigan
avantage à joe biden même si c'est un
avantage extrêmement serrée pour le
moment les derniers dépouillement
données 49,5 pour joe biden contre 48,9
bon sens pour donald trump la caroline
du nord avantage
en revanche au candidat républicain
c'est que la géorgie ou donald trump a
également un avantage la pennsylvanie on
vous en parle évidemment depuis le début
de cet état extrêmement important et
bien c'est un avantage à trump mais
grosse incertitude car un million de
votes par correspondance restent à
dépouiller je vous propose justement
d'écouter le gouverneur de pennsylvanie
qui s'exprimait ce matin sur ce
dépouillement il promet une forme de
démocratie que tous ces votes seront
comptés il tient à être rassurant
écoutez vous reconnaîtrez peut-être même
pas les résultats aujourd'hui
mais le plus important est que nous
ayons des résultats fiables
encore une fois même si cela prend un
peu plus de temps que ce à quoi nous
sommes habitués
ne vous y trompez pas notre démocratie
est mise à l'épreuve dans cette élection
voilà la pennsylvanie donc il ne devrait
pas faire connaître ses résultats
aujourd'hui il faudra encore pas mal de
temps pour dépouiller ac 1 million de
ventes en tout cas sachez une chose il
semblerait si nos calculs sont bons que
si joe biden l'emportent au wisconsin où
vichy gagnent et dans le nevada
il pourrait éventuellement justement se
passer d'une victoire en pennsylvanie à
noter que le vote par correspondance ans
est faible 1 million de votes par
correspondance qui restent à dépouiller
sont en général buteau
traditionnellement à gauche puisque les
électeurs républicains se sont souvent
davantage déplacé en personne dans les
dans les bureaux de vote
en tout cas un constat stéphanie
aujourd'hui c'est une bataille féroce
entre les deux camps à coups de
déclarations interposées
ah bah il fallait s'en douter olivier ça
a débuté hier soir on va essayer d'être
chronologique avec donald trump aux
alentours de deux heures du matin ici
aux etats unis le président qui a
revendiqué la victoire dénonçant des
fraudes massives il a demandé le
recompte des votes menaçant de saisir la
cour suprême le camp d'aïda nuit n'était
pas en reste
il a aussi communiqué joe biden
dénonçant des propos scandaleux sans
précédent joe biden qui lui aussi a
revendiqué une forme de victoire il
s'est montré très optimiste sur sa
victoire à cette élection présidentielle
la bataille des déclarations a fait
ensuite une petite pause pendant
certainement quelques heures de sommeil
pour les deux candidats et puis donald
trump a rouvert les hostilités ce matin
sur son compte twitter alors là c'est
important je fais une petite parenthèse
quand même assez cocasse à noter que la
plupart de ces tweets ce matin trois sur
quatre ont été censurés par le réseau
social je cite au motif que le contenu
est contestée est susceptible d'être
trop peur donald trump en tout cas qui
s'est étonné que l' avantage soit donné
ce matin à baydan écouté hier soir
j'étais en tête souvent bien parti dans
de nombreux états clés dans presque tous
les endroits dirigé et contrôlé par des
démocrates
puis un par un ils ont commencé à
disparaître comme par magie au fur et à
mesure que les bulletins de vote
surprise était content et très étrange
et les sondeurs se sont complètement est
historiquement tromper
est à noter que donald trump a justement
demandé tout à l'heure le décompte total
des ventes dans le wisconsin qui semble
justement acquise à joe biden le
candidat démocrate de son côté n'est
évidemment pas après lui non plus à
lâcher quoi que ce soit il a aussi
communiqué par tweets se met à écouter
nous n'aurons pas de répit tant que le
vote de chacun n'aura pas été comptés
soyez à l'écouté de ma directrice de
campagne
jane au mali dillon et mon conseiller de
campagne bob bauer qui font le point sur
la situation de la course
alors évidemment cette bataille
s'annonce ardue on l'aura bien compris
elle pourrait se terminer devant les
tribunaux de toute façon donald trump
avait déjà prévenu qu'il craignait des
fraudes massives il faut savoir qu'aux
états unis ce sont les tribunaux des
états fédérés qui vont être compétent
dans ce domaine s'il ya une contestation
de leurs décisions et bien ce sera après
au congrès d'agir et la cour suprême
pourrait ainsi se saisir on se souvient
en 2007 bataille entre al gore et de
george bush notamment en floride qui
portait sur quelques voix george bush
avait alors demandé le recomptage des
votes
finalement al gore avait renoncé à
saisir les tribunaux essai de george
bush qui avait remporté la victoire
merci beaucoup stéphanie pour ces
précisions stéphanie vous restez avec
nous pour décrypter avec nos invités à
les dernières actualités de cette
élection présidentielle pleine de
rebondissements